did david hasselhoff really find you on
a plane and discover you and that's how
your acting career started is that
really true because you read [ __ ] and
you're like
that is really now i i have this picture
of him sitting in seat 3d
and he's now he was on one of those
planet hollywood planes he was
even better
and you were on the plane
yep and he
came up to you tell me the story
and he um he came up to me and he was
like i have this show
and
you would be perfect for it and i wasn't
even an actor
you know i was a model you hadn't
studied acting you hadn't studied or you
hadn't done anything
nothing wow nothing
and um
i mean like i did you know like drama my
senior year in high school
and you know everybody said i was good
at it and i made some people cry and i
was like okay whatever um
[Laughter]
and so
yeah he did and i was like oh that's
very nice thank you very much i mean i
didn't want to be rude i was like i'm
actually not an actor and he was like
well you should be and you know let me
send you this stuff i was like oh no no
it's okay no sorry
whatever
and then um the people that i was with
on the um plane one of them went in
on an audition for the show that he was
talking about and he was like you were
with that girl
and
she was like yes and and
get her in here can you bring her in
here and i went in and
i got it you you read you read a scene
with david
i think
yes yes i did and it was enough
it was enough he looked at you did he
tell you right then this is yours
were you scared out of your socks
you had never acted before now you're
going to be on baywatch nights what the
what were you how much preparation did
you do and how
how did you approach this
i mean
i just went in there and
it was very jimmy stewart i just knew my
lines i didn't bump into the furniture
and they liked it i guess
but you know what you'll love this story
oh my god you're gonna love this all
right and i've never told this story
before okay good are you ready yes okay
you are strapped in for this
man i got a seatbelt on my chair
there you go all right
okay so when i was a model
um
and you know going to clubs and bars and
all that stuff and it was so awesome and
there were so many creative and talented
gifted people gifted and one of the
people that i knew
was this i mean
devastatingly handsome african-american
gentleman and he was the drummer
for eric clapton
wow and
somehow we were all together one night
and you know all of us were singing and
all that kind of stuff and he was like
you need to sing
and i was like oh thanks for so sweet he
was no angie i'm serious like you need
to sing he was like you should come you
should go audition for eric and i was
like uh
okay
and he set up a time and he set up the
studio and all that and i didn't go
uh-huh what
and i didn't go because i was scared and
i was you know like oh my god i just i
didn't go
so i run into him about probably about a
month later
and i've got some more experience under
my belt and i'm kind of like oh okay and
i walked up to him you know like a
nonchalant lackadaisical young stupid
person does and i was like hey you know
you know what i'm i'm ready to do that
can you can you reschedule it and he
just looks when he was like no
that ship has failed
and i mean when i said like oh my god
i'm breaking out just sweats it's a
story
i was so embarrassed oh my god my hands
are shaking i was so mortified i was
just
and you know what he said
he looked at me and he goes you see you
know that feeling that you're feeling
right now
anyway yes and he goes don't ever feel
it again
and i never have
in other words you took the bull by the
horns you you you
never missed an opportunity again when
you had it never
wow
how about that he called you out on your
[ __ ] and it changed you yeah
totally if you wouldn't have done that
that day you think you'd have been doing
the same [ __ ]
probably i mean like i said i think
god's had a really big hand in my path
but i mean can you beli how
transformative like what an incredi i've
never seen him since
i don't remember his name i would only
know his face he had the most handsome
face he had like the whitest most
perfect teeth he was so beautiful
and like
i mean
you know that feeling you're feeling
right now
never feel it again
you